in a room lit only by torchlight a free
syrian army rebel is bound to a car tire
his captors are also rebels but they are
Islamist jihadis and they believe this
man has insulted their God he pleads his
innocence screaming that he is a Muslim
fighter like them but there is no let-up
even the metal baton used is broken into
this video was uploaded to Facebook less
than two weeks ago on the account of a
man thought to be from London currently
fighting in Syria he uses a pseudonym to
hide his identity but his admission of
involvement is clear some FSA are
starting to feel they run things he
writes this FSA scam never thought we
would jump out at them and pick them up
too then got ahead of themselves and
swore at Allah at this point there was
no stopping us the account has been
monitored and verified as that of a
British citizen by the International
Centre for the study of radicalization
at King's College in London footage is
quite remarkable because it shows the
torture of an individual who is himself
a Syrian rebel so this is rebel on rebel
violence which is something we've been
hearing quite a bit about but you're
seeing the involvement allegedly at
least of British citizens for the first
time
other British fighters such as this man
also thought to be from London use their
social media to post updates of their
jihad this Twitter post shows prisoners
he claims to have caught got these
criminals today God willing they will be
killed tomorrow can't wait for that
feeling when you just killed someone
later he posts this image to Facebook a
bloody hand with the caption my first
time in the days following the
photograph is posted on jihadi social
media as a propaganda image researchers
from King's College contacted this man
to ask about the posts he claimed the
men shown were not killed but sent for
further interrogation and that torture
is against his religion
they also stress that they are in Syria
purely for humanitarian reasons and that
they've gone there to help the Syrian
people overthrow the tyranny of the
Assad regime in that context they do
admit to fighting but they don't really
understand a lot of the concern or the
fear back home but despite their
protestations their posts appear to tell
a different story one that indicates
some British fighters in Syria have been
involved in and witnessed - some
horrific acts of violence just last week
the first suicide attack by a British
citizen who's said to have been carried
out in Aleppo all this a terrifying
prospect for British authorities already
nervous that such violence might one day
come home Tom Rayner Sky News